[Music]
welcome to Hannity and tonight there is
frankly no other way to put it but
America is in rough shape and Joe Biden
your president he's pretty much uh the
one person you can blame now our
soldiers they are under attack Biden
does little to respond cargo ships are
targeted by terrorists while Joe just
looks the other way the southern border
has been an unmitigated disaster for
three plus years and Biden he just
pretends that all is fine the economy is
in an inflationary nightmare but the
President says it's never been better
but these are just a few of the very
serious problems that the president now
has to face ahead of
2024 and Biden will also need to contend
with a looming impeachment proceeding
that has been credibly accused of public
corruption he has been and the evidence
of wrongdoing that is subst substantial
although the media as usual just wants
to cover for all things Biden now the
bottom line is Vice President Joe Biden
took official actions that benefited his
son and his son's foreign business
partners at the very same time the Biden
family has been making millions from
these very same foreign Partners some of
our top geopolitical foes and according
to Hunter a lot of that money went to
the big guy himself Hunter meanwhile is
an accused tax cheat is now facing
felony char es with speculation that
pharoh violations implicating his father
could soon be on the way now naturally
after years of non-stop bogus witch
hunts against Trump well many Democrats
now they have suddenly lost their
appetite for impeachment Russia
collusion truther Jamie Rasin is now
reportedly working behind the scenes on
Capitol Hill begging Republican
lawmakers not to move forward with
proceedings now put simply Democrats
they are in a state of Panic the vast
majority of you the American people
nearly 70% believe that your President
Joe Biden illegally and unethically was
involved in his son's business deals now
that number is only going to get worse
with the bright lights of an impeachment
proceeding now sadly Joe doesn't really
seem to have the ability to defend
himself and As Trump said it's not even
clear that Biden even knows he's alive
so today he looked totally completely
utterly confused confounded unsure of
his surroundings yet again at an event
in Philly during his brief remarks Biden
failed to address the most or most
pressing issues of our time and instead
fil time with one of his very favorite
tall tals about his wife a house fire
and his beloved Corvette you know the
one that was next to all the top secer
classifi documents uh but they didn't
rate his house take a look I also saved
my home and my my wife's life when I was
away it was the last day uh that uh the
most famous guy doing Meet the Press uh
in Washington DC and I was doing the
program and uh what happened was uh
there was a lightning struck a little
Pond behind my house hit a wire came up
through the basement of my home and
three stories and the smoke literally
ended up being that thick literally that
thick you've seen it you guys have seen
it
I wasn't there and my wife was there and
my my dog and my cat and my 67 Corvette
but all kid aside they saved my wife and
got her out saved my
home now according to authorities the
fire was Tiny it was very small it was
contained to the kitchen it was put out
almost immediately without any injuries
minimal damage to the house but that has
not stopped Joe Biden from telling that
rambling embellished version of that
story now what dozens of times since
taking office but it gets even worse
you're going to love this on Friday a
big number well let's just say got the
best of Joe take a look look I own
couple shotguns I I I I haven't shot
them in a while because I used to
usually just make target practice ski
shooting and all the studies show by the
way you get from people get from point A
to point B faster on a train than their
car they take the train they take the
train over a billion 300 million
trillion 300 million they started off
making fun of it calling the bomic well
guess what it is bomic we have a lot
more to do to put our plan is already
paying
off I made a commitment that nobody
making less than 400,000 bucks a year
which is way above what I ever made
until I became
president but was look
by the way he hasn't mentioned bomic in
over a 100 days uh now he's back to the
lie about uh couples making $400,000 a
year we have debunked that lie too now
in Cas in case you missed the important
part let me read it to you verbatim over
a billion 300 million trillion $300
million hello I need a calculator
somebody help me now bad news for Joe
his trouble with numbers is now extend
ending to poll numbers look at Michigan
Joe is losing by a whopping 10 points to
Donald Trump look at a CNN poll in
Georgia Biden is down by five in a
hypothetical matchup against Trump and
according to a brand new Wall Street
Journal poll Trump is beating Biden by
Four Points Nationwide by and large the
American people feel betrayed by Joe's
failed policies and by the way do not
believe that he's mentally capable of
even carrying out the duties of
president one Democratic pollster is
citing all these numbers as quote Grim
but be warned Democrats do have
something up their sleeve and that is a
secret weapon so to speak and her name
they're now bringing on the services of
Hillary rodm Clinton according to
reports the Biden campaign is now ready
to deploy Hillary to help the president
sagging poll numbers in campaign that's
the same Hillary Clinton that lost badly
to Donald Trump and 2016 and then of
course uh said it was an illegitimate
election nobody seemed to care when she
said it the same Hillary Clinton that
never bothered to even visit Wisconsin
the same Hillary Clinton who has been
described as toxic to voters and of
course we are very early in the election
season the first primary has yet to
taken place but this is not good for Joe
Biden it's not good for the Democratic
party and every week it seems to get
worse and worse and worse hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else